Leto Atreides ii known to the universe
as the god Emperor ruled over all of
mankind from 102 o5 AG to 1372 4 AG
throughout his 3,000 year rule Leto had
oppressed mankind in his totalitarian
regime travel between planets was
prohibited for the vast majority of the
imperial inhabitants throughout the
empire the people lived in similar homes
and lived similar lives there was no
progress and people were not free to
seek out their own desires as they had
once been they had peace or at least the
sense of it but no liberty when Leto ii
died so did his empire humanity was
plunged into the famine times for so
long men had relied upon the god emperor
for all of their needs in this time the
natural resources of many planets were
plundered technologies dismantled and
repurposed the scarcity during these
times led to a lot of human suffering
but for the first time in millenia
mankind was free to choose its own
destiny mankind was also wary of another
emperor such as Leto the tyrant as a
result of the famine times and the fear
of another tyrant they looked to the
Stars many chose to flee the old Empire
into the far reaches of space they
traveled further than any humans before
them many different groups sent
representatives into the scattering
including the many desert and the
Bennett laylax this of course was all
part of the god Emperor's Golden Path he
knew that limiting the freedom of people
during his reign would lead to an
explosion of human migration across the
universe once he was dead this spreading
of humanity would ensure humankind's
survival in the long run also the
scattering would spread the no gene that
Leto had created in ciona Atreides this
gene would prevent some humans from
being seen in the
scenes of view therefore the great enemy
which Leto saw would use prescient to
find and destroy all humans could never
succeed but Leto not only meant for
humankind to scatter physically
throughout the cosmos he also wanted
their ideologies to diverge their
technologies and cultures as well
Leto knew that humankind needed to
diversify itself because a stagnant
humankind would have no chance at all at
defeating the great enemy should it
appear evolution was necessary
still the golden path was cruel and Leto
knew that should the enemy appear many
humans would die regardless but he gave
men the ability to hide let them scatter
Duncan let them run and hide anywhere
they want in any universe they choose
during the famine times no ships also
came into existence no ships were space
vessels designed by the ex Ian's
containing technology based on the same
mechanics as Latos dictated the device
he used to secretly record his journals
and also the no room which the
exceiiency used to raise weinery
beyond Latos prescient I know rooms have
the ability to cloak those inside from
the prescient view it is likely that
later the second foresaw the invention
of no rooms and no ships and subtly
encouraged their development in order to
provide another layer of protection for
mankind if the great enemy did arise in
the future though many chose to remain
within the bounds of the old Empire an
immeasurable number of humans fled into
the cosmos and for 1500 years the people
of the old Empire heard nothing of the
lost ones in that time the old Empire
would be reshaped and new and strange
groups would develop among the lost ones
in the scattering eventually one of
these groups the honored mantra is
return out of the scattering having fled
some mysterious enemy which had
decimated their own in
hire the MOT raise were a result of the
intermingling between the many Jesuit
and Latos fish speakers they in essence
were a more ruthless version of the many
Jesuit but without the Sisterhood's
Pranab induce skills and access to other
memories the honored ma tre sought to
dominate the old Empire by force
it is not clear in the original saga
whether or not the great enemy that Leto
foresaw was in fact the enemy that the
honored montrezl fled out of the
scattering in god emperor of doom it is
revealed that Leto feared that the ex
Ian's would create our FL the cloud
darkness of holy judgment a biblical
reference relating to God making
judgment over all mankind
it appears that Leto feared the creation
of a machine one that mankind could not
keep in check a machine god one that
would possess prescient vision and use
it to hunt humankind to extinction it is
possible that the Exxon's
that did go into the scattering created
such a machine exeunt zat work outside
the bounds of the Imperium would not
even have to keep up the pretense of
working within the bounds of the but
Larry in Jihad and it was perhaps that
machine that conquered the Empire of the
honored ma trace and now threatens all
of mankind this is of course speculation
the expanded dune books by Brian Herbert
and Kevin J Anderson provide a
resolution to this which I have covered
in this video focusing on the honored
Mott race it involves the Mott race
encountering the remnants of the Machine
Empire and facing its wrath if you
enjoyed this video feel free to leave a
like and for more dune videos check out
the dune playlist on my channel